when you wish upon a star makes no
difference who you are
but it helps if you have the kind of
cash disney has or the amount of cheddar
sported by pixar
then you can wish for talking toys an
army of fairies
hell you can even buy off woodland
creatures to help you get dressed
in the morning it's the greenest and
greenest of green you
need hello gang my name is mark and
welcome to my small world of versus
where today my pleasant task is simple
disappointing
your inner child
in this episode it's the library of
technologically terrific pixar films
taking on the venerable vault of disney
animated classes
pixar began as kind of sort of rivals to
the goliath disney but now they're all
one big happy family
you know like how iron man and captain
america didn't always see eye to eye
or how luke skywalker had to work to get
his daddy to agree with him politically
oh hey look those are also disney
properties
it may be a small world indeed but today
disney and pixar are going to duke it
out to see who gets a fast pass
to intergalactic cinematic supremacy
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two
tomato meter slash audience score round
three
social impact and then i'll do a wild
card round that will likely involve
which team off more family members in
the first
10 minutes of their movies ah disney and
pixar
we'll tug on your heartstrings after we
rip it out of your chest cavity
let's get it on
[Music]
i can't understand her she's from the
other studio one
box office if scrooge mcduck is swimming
in a pile of gold coins then disney is
floating on a cloud of benjamins
their animation classics have been a
consistent source of cash register sound
effects
since way back in 1940 when snow white
first
took a nap since then disney counts 51
total animated flicks as classics and
they've totaled 15.5
billion dollars at the domestic box
office enough to feed every dalmatian in
the family
it also makes for an impressive average
of 324 million dollars per film
but here comes pixar with their fancy
windows 95 computing machines
since toy story's mid-90s debut
catapulted animation to
infinity and beyond their 21 film
history has amassed
7.76 billion dollars in total domestic
coin
making for an average of 370 million
dollars
every time that adorable lamp turns on
yeah they've actually made 22 flicks but
we left onward off the list because it
only hit theaters weeks before the
pandemic hit
it's lasted a lot longer than we still
hope but at least
there's 73 animated hit movies between
the two to go back and watch
both teams have had a handful of flicks
crossed the one billion dollar mark at
the worldwide box office
but when we adjust for inflation only
snow white
and the seven friend-zoned dwarves
crossed the billion dollar number in the
states alone
bringing up the rear for disney is
2011's winnie the pooh which made just
39 million dollars domestically
but still thanks for noticing me
pixar's 4 is much higher as the good
dinosaur still made 140 million dollars
as the lowest grosser for that company
it's a tough call to see who draws first
cartoon blood
as pixar enjoys a narrow lead with the
overall box office numbers
and when we pull at disney plus and
combine all the films
the bottom 10 grocers are all
representing
team disney though i will point out two
of those flicks
are the black cauldron and the sword and
the stone and they both
slap as the kids on the tack talk say
ha-ha
hilarious furthermore the top ten of the
combined universe's box office digits
reveal
eight disney movies with only the
incredibles two and
finding nemo wiggling into the top ten
the top five are all disney
headlined by snow white 101 dalmatians
and the lion king as the top three
everything the light touches is our
kingdom
for decades all that the light touches
has been owned by
disney but who won this most recent
decade
in breaking news the 2010s are history
and even in that tech
savvy span disney and pixar are neck and
neck
on the strength of franchises like
frozen disney has somehow managed to
remain competitive with pixar to this
very day
i'm not deciding any of these rounds
purely based on nostalgia
as a matter of fact i can't stand
fantasia hot take
but doing it right at the bank for 80
years is certainly enough to be a
tiebreaker in round number one
disney gets the nod and goes up one
nothing
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
okay sure lots of folks have been seeing
disney classics for generations
but is that because they're great or
because for the majority of that time
their only competition at the box office
was
abin costello versus insert movie
monster
which is a flick i would still pay money
to see
according to the tomato meter pixar
movies all 22 this round
have been consistently excellent ever
since we were all chewing cinnaburst
flavor crystals
they averaged 89 percent with toy story
and toy story 2 earning a perfect 100
percent
toy story 3 fell way off the wagon and
landed with a thud
at 98 percent
[Music]
at the back of the pack is cars 2
sputtering its way to a 39 percent
even though i liked it should i not have
admitted that
really the tomato meter also favors
disney as those 51 movies average an
easily fresh
75 percent thanks in large part to bread
winners like aladdin at 95 percent
zootopia 98 and pinocchio's nose strings
attached perfect 100 percent
anchoring disney are some recent flicks
like chicken little and brother bear
at 37 percent doesn't mean the sky is
falling but it's still
rotten if we take a gander at the
combined top ten
each house can brag about five movies
making the cut
but the bottom ten is all disney except
for of course
cars too the worst film ever me hey
who put that that wasn't me that was an
editor sorry mater
wasabi oh same old samo what's up with
you soy merida and the rest of the pixar
gang are smelling victory
but not so fast how about the audience
score
disney lives up to its reputation of
being the happiest place on earth with a
75 percent fresh
across the board and movies like beauty
and the beast at 92 percent
and big hero 6 at 94 percent highlight
at the top
but once again pixar flexes its family
of superhero muscle
with an even fresher 83 percent average
on the strength of scores like 95
for onward and 94 for coco
and now the question i hate asking
because it doesn't even matter anymore
what was the lowest audience score for
each disney has home on the range at 29
and pixar you guessed it heck you
probably voted for it
cars 2 at 49 hey
it's not the lowest it beat home on the
range by 20.
yahtzee pixar gets the win in round two
and vrooms into a one-one tie with
disney
punch me guido punch me in the face this
is the most glorious day of my life
round three
social impact however you want to gauge
the impact that these two beloved
entities had on society
you're gonna find it in abundance
don't believe me uh just go outside
shirts bumper stickers
fast food tie-ins i did extensive
research on that angle myself
the merchandising alone has been a
multi-billion dollar industry for disney
and pixar
but to look at their impact on high
society let's put on our glass slippers
and attend the most elegant ball of the
year
the oscars oh my god
yes nowadays we have a whole category
dedicated to the best animated film of
the year
and this creation was in large part
thanks to pixar's consistently great
output
since the addition of the extra statue
in 2001 pixar has been nominated 13
times
and won an astounding 10 times disney's
been competitive
in the way that phil has been competing
with tiger 11 nominations but only three
wins
however twas beauty and the beast that
shattered the glass ceiling for
animation
when it earned an outright best picture
nomination in 1992
that paved the road for pixar films up
and toy story 3
to also be nominated for the highest
prize in all of movidum
beauty and the beast would end up losing
to silence of the lambs
although i'm pretty sure beast and
hannibal lecter would have enjoyed a
great meal of
fava beans chianti and gaston
[Music]
but if we're talking awards and societal
impact let's crank up the tunes
disney being legendary for its
inspirational songs is a tale as old as
time
and randy newman has helped pixar carry
that torch
into the new millennium dude loves la
but he really loves the oscars
pixar films have been nominated for best
original song eight times
winning thrice for monsters inc toy
story 3
and coco when we all remembered just how
much we could cry at a movie
disney has been dominant in this
category since winning for when you wish
upon a star
way back in 1940. they totaled 20
nominations and
eight wins total most recently for
frozen's let it go
my apologies to any parents out there
who after years of trying
finally got that song out of their heads
it's back now
likely permanent
when we look at how the films are
regarded it's an avalanche of adoration
when any respected movie publication
ranks their best animated films
it's a heap of disney and pixar
favorites and in time magazine's list
pinocchio was number one and dumbo and
the little mermaid were also in the top
10.
joining them was pixar's favorite
dumpster droid wally at number two
plus up finding nemo and the south park
movie also made the top 10.
how's that uh south park i guess is not
a pixar movie
that's on me you know for a clownfish he
really isn't that funny
pity we regard toy story highway for
changing movies forever by being the
first computer-rendered animated film
rightfully so but disney has been making
cinematic innovations
since the beginning snow white and the
seven guys willing to give her a ride to
the airport
broke new ground by being the first
feature-length cell animated movie
then lady in the [ __ ] pioneered
anamorphic widescreen
aspect ratio not to mention giving us
the most romantic way to eat chef
boyardee
in the 90s tarzan ushered in a new dawn
of classic animation when he utilized a
technology
known as deep canvas which sounds like
it could actually be a genesis album
title
shout out phil collins
so after considering all the
achievements awards technological
breakthroughs
and rankings it's a good battle to win
round three
and i'm not giving disney the nod based
solely on them having a significant
amount of seniority
but if we're talking societal impact and
our world is nothing without strong
women
how can you deny the disney princesses
elegant
bold beautiful and if you've seen ralph
breaks the internet
you know they're tough as nails and
while a newer generation might fall in
love with pixar more
what tends to precede having children
well that's a wedding
a wedding and while i'm sure there's
been a handful of
monsters ink themed nuptial ceremonies
or in my birthplace of north carolina a
cars themed honeymoon
disney weddings are the best and the
most expensive
do you want to get married at disneyland
have at it if your daddy's last name is
warbucks
if not join the legion of couples who
have had the perfect disney themed
wedding
all over the world good round pixar but
disney brought out the princesses and
the rings
so your carriage has turned back into a
pumpkin disney wins this frame
and goes up two to one
and now it's time for the wild card
round iconic moments
yes today's x factor is that special
sauce that keeps us coming back for more
after all critics and audiences alike
wouldn't be rushing
back to the theater time and time again
to see the social influence of these
movies
if there wasn't the promise of another
iconic moment
a scene a song or a let's be honest
death that hits all five of the emotions
from inside out
oh no we're crying there's no doubt that
walt disney is the icon of memorable
moments in the classic films that bear
his beloved brand
but in the time since he began his
cryotherapy
pixar has managed to take his unique
formula of heartbreak
adventure and magic and weave that into
their modern masterpieces
and i'll be honest for me this round
consists of two categories
great moments and great moments that
will turn me into a puddle of quivering
weeping mush there's a lot of love out
there you know who man
don't embarrass me fillmore and because
it took me like three hours to get my
makeup on for this
let's start with the non-tear-jerking
segment from the first time we see the
toys come to life in toy story
through the discovery of the next life
in coco pixar moments thrive on
inspiring our imagination the action
sequences in the incredibles films are
great templates
that first scene where they all fight
alongside each other as a family
is it once thrilling hilarious and
heartfelt
i'm also going to toss in jack jack
versus the raccoon and the incredibles
2.
it's basically my mom against her bevy
of forest dwellers
every morning back home in virginia love
you mom
and although disney is known more for
the power of a soaring musical number
how about sarah mclaughlin's when she
loved me montage in toy story 2
chills and then tears and then more
tears
sully and mike earning scares in the
unique landscape of monsters inc as
another highlight
as is carl's dogging up saying what all
dogs are thinking
but whenever i think of up it just leads
me to
uh oh they're here not yet not yet
how about disney first scene that comes
to my head is iconic is that magical
kiss that awakens snow white
followed closely by sleeping beauty when
maleficent shows her final form
at the end of the film it brings epic
excitement to this very day
and sure we have all time heralded
legendary moments like
james earl jones passing the torch's
mufasa robin williams going full robin
as the genie
and copper saving todd in the fox and
the hound but if you want one long
iconic disney moment feast your eyes on
robin hood
yeah the jungle book and the rescuers
also have great talking animals but
robin hood
is not only a great disney movie it's
the best robin hood flick
ever and this coming from a guy who
loves kevin costner
you know it's true everything i do i do
it
for fox robin and fox marion ah hey
no wonder disney bought fox romance has
had a premium with disney
as evidenced in everything from
cinderella's legendary time
dance dance dancing the night away to
lady and the tramp's beautiful night
up through tiana finding her mate in the
princess and the frog
recent disney entries like lilo and
stitch frozen and the wreck-it ralph
franchise
have also brought back the big laughs
for adults and children alike
and disney isn't shy about going far out
too
just check out the pink elephant scene
in dumbo
it is super trippy but now that we've
touched on dumbo
here it comes time to unload the emotion
every time i see dumbo it's the scene
where him and his mom who was unfairly
imprisoned under very suspicious
circumstances
rub trunks for maybe the last time and
the singing in the background
oh god here it comes let's go every
time i care more about those fictional
elephants than i do most people i know
in real
actual life that's the power of disney
[Music]
bambi losing her mom at the outset of
her adventure aladdin granting genie his
freedom
mulan saving all of china with so much
gut wrenching it's nice that we have
all-time musical numbers like the little
mermaids under the sea
and the jungle books the bare
necessities to fall back on oh
what's that you still have more guts to
wrench don't worry our friends at pixar
studied the disney playbook well
try to watch the beginning of up without
a box of tissues
go ahead i dare you and if you have any
left
head over to the end of coco and see how
long until you need another case
both pixar and the disney classics love
touching on all of our emotions
and in the end that's the lesson sure we
walk into the theater hoping for
fun laughs romance but we leave
realizing that nothing great in life
comes for free
to experience personal growth we must
first endure loss
and to truly find love one must conquer
heartache it's the meaning of life
served in the lovable form of a talking
animal or a family of superheroes
or a rodent who makes a mean ratatouille
yes the past can't
hurt but the way i see it you can either
run from it
or learn from it pixar has done so
much in the two and a half decades
they've been around and if they continue
at this pace
generations may feel the same attachment
that so many of us and our ancestors
have felt
about disney you tell me when i saw this
woman we are talking about the greater
good but at this point in time
in the year 2525 the eldest of disney
classics are 80 years old
and they still inspire the youngest of
us humans they had a 55-year head start
on pixar
and despite the young upstart giving
them a good game disney wins this round
and thus takes the match the call never
bothered me anyway
the beauty of animated films is that
while the technology may change
they'll always be in demand so prepare
for more great moments and enduring
memories from disney and pixar
in prepping for this vid i asked our
expert researcher mark hoffmeyer
which iconic moment from wally he wanted
me to mention
his response the whole movie is one big
iconic moment
and that's the fun of these debates the
real answer is in the eye of the
beholder
you are the only one who can pull the
metaphorical sword
from the proverbial stone that's
hoffmeier's truth
for me i just think wally is a decent
movie about an underdog garbage robot
dating way out of his league with a
futuristic ipod and they
enter into a loveless marriage for all
eternity
now if it was a disney movie we'd have
gotten more show tunes and maybe wall-e
rolls a trash meatball over to eve and
we all go
ah but you know what if it was also a
disney movie
we'd probably have met eve's dad who's a
walkman
in the opening credits only to find out
that he's dead because his double a's
ran out
their parents are dead so we've had our
turn and i went with disney
but now everything the light touches is
yours
the fate of two of the most profitable
entities in movie history
is in your hands dear viewer comment
right now
with your vote and let us know your
favorite moment in either's celebrated
history
oh oh sorry sir no one was listening i'm
mark ellis reminding you to click that
like button
and i'll close out with one last
scorching hot take
the chimichangas at disneyland are
better than the turkey legs
i know i know the legs photograph better
for your instagram feed
but them chimichangas will fill you up
for three days on
pure deliciousness they're right next to
the indiana jones ride
which is also a disney property right
kinda
i don't know i'm making this up as i go
along
[Applause]
you